Firebase provides a full set of
authentication options which can be
easily configured.
Options include email password,
Google, Facebook, GitHub, and Twitter.
Documentation is provided for
each option.
When a user authenticates in Firebase,
a token is generated which is valid for
the length of time specified
in the Firebase log in and
auth page under session length.
For e-mail password authentication
Firebase compares the e-mail password
against a stored hash and
then generates a Firebase token.
For social providers such as Google,
Firebase gets an OAuth token from
the provider in
the authentication process and
then generates a Firebase token.
Let's briefly look at the user log in
authentication screen in Firebase.
Here you see the user log in and
authentication screen inside
the Firebase application.
You can enable email and password or
other social providers here.
For email and password and for
Google, Lila will show you
how to configure these as authentication
methods, but before that,
let's take a brief look at some of the
methods you can use for authentication.
Remember, these methods
are provided by Firebase.
As a developer, all you have to do is
call them and Firebase does the rest.
createUser() creates a new account
with a specified email and password.
Auth with password attempts to
authenticate the fire base with giving
credentials.
Auth with OAuth token attempts to
authenticate the Firebase within
an OAuth token and
the on off method listens for
changes in the user's
authentication state.
This is useful when you want to
determine the authentication state of
a user, and subsequently force
a user to log in if necessary.